three-year-old darren was diagnosed with
leukemia at the age of just four weeks
chemotherapy and a bone marrow
transplant couldn't keep the cancer at
bay
so aaron and her family were forced to
travel from county gildare to london for
a revolutionary new treatment
what did you have why were you in the
hospital
because i had a book a book
yeah
where were we do you remember where we
had to go to the hospital
in london
yeah we had to go to london the
treatment at great ormond street
hospital known as car t cell therapy was
seen as aaron's last chance
it was yeah that's what they said
palliative care if we hadn't had the
option to go to london it would have
been palliative care it just managed the
pain pain management yeah but uh
thankfully
it all worked out and
there's the result it's brilliant
car t therapy involves taking a
patient's own t cells and effectively
reprogramming them to better target
cancer the cells are then infused back
into the patient
the cannas were just one of at least
seven irish families that have had to
make the difficult trip to britain to
access this life-saving treatment but
from today for the first time irish
families can access the new therapy here
at this children's hospital in dublin
we're indebted to our uk colleagues and
being able to help us treat our patients
and we could not and but we're delighted
today to be able to announce that the
car journey for our patients is far
simplified
and the first child to have the
treatment and home turf is 15 year old
alex
it means a lot to me because
i would have
been having it in england
if it wasn't
for all the
progress that we've made so i'm gonna be
the first child to have it in ireland a
difficult journey made easier for
children like alex and aaron but she's
only really excited by her fourth
birthday this friday even if it is hard
to keep track of the years
stephen murphy sky news dublin